[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to week four of
the protests League as always my name is
Caleb bendy and I'm joined by the
wonderful International Master dorsa
Derrick Shani and today we're gonna be
covering our match against the
California unicorns but before that why
don't we see where all the teams stand
so far into this season with the team
standings here we can see in our Western
Division there is one team ahead of us
and that is the Canada chess pros
so we'll definitely be looking to to
make up some some ground here this week
and it's the California unicorns who
currently stand in 4th place
of course the chess bras and the
Archbishop's are the only teams to go
undefeated
I believe this far into the season with
the New York marshals and the unicorns
following close behind the e-string that
central divisions are also quite a close
race over there with a few teams heading
up the leaderboards in each division
well dorsa the standings seem to show it
and I think the fans seem to think it as
well but the chess bras possibly our
number one rival what do you think we do
have a good chance against em but I kind
of want to see how this game goes today
because we also have well we are favored
in I want to say every board yeah we're
actually favored in all 16 games here
today so it should go well for us but
it'll all be decided next week probably
against the Tres pros that's when we
play them I feel like that if today we
can really very decisively then for next
round we have a more like a calm eased
mind yes definitely
want to go in from a strong position
here yeah but why don't we actually
check out the format of the games today
we have let's see teams from four
continents and it is a truly global
league then I guess of course in our
western division we have quite a few
countries representatives as well
although mainly US team
in North American teams there are 24
teams in the 2020 protests League season
with seven of the top ten players in the
world of course you have a good portion
of those on our state lewis archbishops
team the time control is ten minutes
with a two second increment in each game
and of course you get one point for
every game you win a half point for
every game you draw you know then
there's a key ten points added to your
score if you win the match and that's
how you get that number that we just saw
in the standings where we have like 60
some points and as do the chess for us
yeah because it's specifically like this
format a lot because drawers are such a
common it happens so commonly that you
would prefer to see some more action and
this way you get to see more action
every players trying their best to try
and get those ten points yes
extra points yeah and even if you secure
the win for the match there's still a
lot to play it for it each when you get
adding another point to your team's
score of course the the final four teams
once we get through this state main
season here and then through the
playoffs the final four will compete in
a live final so all the players will
travel out for all the teams and compete
in person for the final four yeah I do
remember once it does in San Francisco
yeah I believe last year there right
yeah that was that was pretty awesome I
thought it I wasn't there but just some
of my slew teammates and well the
archbishop teammates were there and I
thought it was pretty cool that they
were like right there playing still
online but there yeah they kind of have
the the pro gamer set up you have the
monitors just kind of facing against
each other so the players are right up
against each other but they're still
playing on on chess comm yeah pretty
close I really thought that was like wow
like you're sitting right there so you
could just pick up a chess board in
plants but instead you are playing
against a computer you're like you're
not really looking at your opponents
right particularly yes it's an
interesting take on
yeah and definitely will be will be
hoping to get back there again this year
of course we want to take the number one
spot in our division because that gives
us a leg up in the playoffs where it
really all counts so a lot to play for
why don't we actually check out what the
pairings are like against it we said I
think we're actually favored on all four
boards for all four of the games here
are the round one pairings you see there
for the Archbishop's we actually have
the dream team Bobby on board one
dominguez on board to Wesley so on board
three and liam lee on board for all 27
hundredths playing for these these
Archbishop's here notably board one for
the California unicorns is daro spirits
a former Archbishop himself he made it
to the the final four I think a couple
years ago and played for our team and
smite comer before the show told me he
he blew it
he lost a lot of games when he went to
that live boy finals so we kicked him
out he is not an archbishop anymore he
ran away to the California unicorns
where I mean he still lives in San Luis
yeah it's true but yeah it's and I feel
like our team is strong enough it's I
like her team as it is yeah I also
wanted to mention more to Gregorio
Oberyn is also a Missouri player he
actually goes to Mizzou University and
he was also looking to be an archbishop
but we have so many slew players but we
decided to stick with one one University
at a time so he as well joining the
California unicorns board three and
Daniel Meredith ski was also recently in
st. Louis playing in one of our closed
events Invitational I think it was the
the Winter Classic that that he played
in I could be wrong but very often he
comes here and then Steven Zurich also a
former Grand Master in residence in st.
Louis so actually quite out quite a few
familiar faces on these California
unicorns that were taking on of course
you can join us here on YouTube where
keep an eye on the YouTube chat we've
got Stefan here in chat and Devin
someone just with the initials FS and so
you can follow the games here on our
YouTube stream as well as live on chess
comm they'll be broadcast there for all
to see here is our schedule as well this
week of course we have the California
unicorns and I think we're the last
round of the day for this Western
Division earlier today you could have
seen the Krakens take on the capybaras
the Lions take on the chest bras and the
Marshalls take on Chicago went but yet
but at the moment we've all been waiting
for the key matchup is us against for
California unicorns yeah I also wanted
to mention about Mizzou because last
semester like this academic year is the
first year that they actually have a
chess team and Christine korilla yeah is
the coach there and it's kind of funny
because he's one of the best friends
with my coach Islander room here so it's
kind of funny that they both have chess
programs and like sister universities a
very friendly rivalry there yeah of
course and I did what I mention Gregorio
Prynne who is the Mizzou player has
actually had an astounding start to this
year I think he has something like three
and a half out of four four games that
he's played and a well over 2,800
performance rating this far into the end
of the season yeah he's a very good
player he's not Fabiana he's not Fabiana
that's that's a good way to put it he's
not Linea Dominguez and he's not Wesley
so I don't think he's evenly Emily I
completely agree with that statement
of course our board four is actually
higher rated than their board one Dara's
squeeze so we're looking to run up the
score a little bit today although
nothing nothing is certain in chests of
course yeah I feel like in chess it's
really important that you just like
there's this phrase don't lose your cool
I feel like if our players keep their
cool yeah they should have a pretty
Pleasant - two and a half hours yeah
it's all about finding your form not not
letting a loss here they're really get
to you just playing your best chess and
standing on top in this game
I mean I'm kind of wondering cuz three
of our four players are out of the
continent if I'm not mistaken yeah I
think they're all still hanging out in
in Gibraltar maybe yeah I was in
Gibraltar too is like should be
traveling as I've taught let's do yeah
so yeah well I mean Wesley so he's he's
been a real trooper playing in airports
playing in hotels he does whatever it
takes to show up for us here on the
earth bishops so I think we're just a
couple minutes away from getting started
here it is 316 which is a minute past
the scheduled start time but I'm sure
the games will be going in just a few
moments here let's see anything else you
want to talk about before we get going
we could mention the lights going off in
Gibraltar tournament oh I didn't I
didn't hear it both so I saw pictures
and some of my friends are playing there
so I'm also following the tournaments
and I saw pictures of how they're like
if I'm not taken in round 3 went off in
the hotel completely so they were like
playing we're like one of these like old
fluorescent lights break out the candles
they didn't do candles surprisingly I do
have experience firsthand with candles
okay so that's was um yeah that was some
nice throwbacks for me yeah well why
don't you actually take a look at the
full Archbishop's roster of course we
have the the top four players here today
for us that is Fabi Lenny a Wesley and
Liam Lee of course someone you have not
seen yet the very exciting Geoffrey
Zhang is perhaps a very very strong
board for as well who hasn't yet got the
chance to show his stuff but he's a new
Archbishop this year we're hoping to get
him some action Benjamin Bach I believe
played last week he's also playing for
st. Louis he did fairly well touring two
out of four on board for and Nicolas
theodoro as well as another player who
we've we've seen play scoring two and a
half out of four on his board for
performance very impressive stuff
from the International Master of course
other players you might recognize from
previous years we've got Josh bloomer
there on on the lower end of the roster
along with Julian / like Oh Julian of
course making his appearance in
California last year for the World
Championship winning team and there's
one more familiar name dorsa you are
also on the roster as well hopefully
we'll get you get to see you you play
some games whatever is best for the team
I'm happy with that
yeah what openings are we expecting to
see is a question from John last week
they had so many berlin's lots of Berlin
well NEA has been the real Berlin player
in Kalihi he mixes it up yeah look at me
45 yeah I'm gonna go with Bunsen neither
some Marilyn's okay oh I want to see it
dragon yeah maybe maybe we'll see what
happens but of course here I guess
you're a big you for plan yeah fan
personally I'd like to see some more d4
Oh Vegas is where I'm comfortable what I
like talking about I also I mean I feel
like who one of those lines that is kind
of interesting to play but it's not like
you can use your human instincts and mix
of a computer right is like Catalan yeah
so I feel like that's it be like nice
mix to see because we could see probably
some new ideas I could use in my games
yeah yes dude doing this commentary is
is actually sometimes helpful for the
chess game seeing what ideas these
players have of the opening seeing how
their they handle certain positions is
very nice so yeah once again the time
control is gonna be 10 minutes with a
two second increment which is actually
new this year it's down from 15 minutes
plus two so the players have even less
time to think and time is are all the
more present as a factor yeah once again
you see that the format there with that
10 minute and with a two-second
increment time control well why don't we
actually take a look at the schedule for
occurring next week as well I can't
really hype this this up enough because
next week
yeah is it a week where we take
the Canada chest bras you see us they're
top billing at 10 a.m. Pacific Standard
Time that is of course 12 p.m. Central
time here in st. Louis and this is
really going to be the matchup to look
out for so next Monday at 12 p.m.
Central Time 10:00 p.m. Pacific time be
sure to tune in because that's where I
think the the top two places in the
division might be decided right then and
there the chest bras against the
Archbishop's of course you can watch
those other guys later if you want but
really the one to look out for
Archbishop's chest bras next Monday at
10:00 a.m. Pacific time 12 p.m. local
time here in st. Louis with that of
Mines
like we said we're favored on 16 out of
16 games here so what what score are you
hoping to see from from the large
patients here today hoping or
realistically realistically what do you
what do you think um I'm gonna go for 12
to 14 12 to 14 yeah I think that's a
good number
I think what uh what we can hope for is
you know Bobby and Lenny a let's let's
say they both win every game I trust him
and then board three and four let's just
get some draws so I think three out of
four is a good goal for each round each
gets us to that that twelve marker I
think twelve is a nice score to get yeah
I was also just thinking um so Dario
just switched from Poland to us about
maybe a year it should go yeah and so
what I was thinking um he might be
hoping to play us championship this year
which well I don't think that the
invites have gone out yet but he should
be one of the viable candidates and so
if he does plan on playing that US
Championship then here is like how do
you say it's practice room practice
right yeah these top players cuz of
course you're going to see Fabi there
yeah to see Wesley there you're going to
see Lenny into me yes and lammle
probably not gonna play in the US
Championships not maybe not this year
yeah maybe we'll get him to switch
Federation's as well just collect all
these
under grandmasters here yeah but yeah
it'll be interesting to see how daro
handles playing these top players and
maybe it'll give us a little sneak peek
of what to expect to come late March
early April for that I think sure but I
think probably another week or two
before they have a clear idea who or who
is going to be invited or like the wild
cards and stuff so yeah so once again if
you do want to follow the games for
yourself we are gonna be showing them
here once they get started but you can
also go to chess calm and then if you
find chess TV and their official stream
from their page and let's see maybe we
can go there the little TV icon on the
left there it's a struggles yeah you see
where it says today I left further left
further left okay click on that live
chess TV you end up here and then you
scroll down just a bit and you click on
archbishops you will automatically
follow all four of the Archbishop's and
you'll see all the games once they get
going
so neat three if you need to know how to
follow all the players that's how you
can do it quick and easy on chess calm
and now all the games will appear once
once they get started so yeah it looks
like we are running just a little bit
behind schedule I'm sure that's the age
of Internet okay go get going
as soon as as soon as they can one of
the things that I kind of like about
playing physical opponents like right
there and then yeah mrs. zero-tolerance
also I mean so if you're not there at
the zero tolerance time you lose or like
if it's like when they start the game if
you're a little bit late like they start
on time yeah unless there's a some some
very honest but unexpected disaster they
start on time so either you're there or
you have to like run to there and you're
a little always like out of breath and
yeah so that is that is something nice
about
over the board tournaments yes well I
mean usually they get started on
schedule sometimes things get delayed
like the lights go off or yeah things of
that nature but yeah organizing a huge
online event like this I'm sure is no
easy yeah I can't even imagine how
they're doing it
oh yeah so as we said today is week four
of seven and so this is I guess the
halfway mark for us here yeah in st.
Louis so a lot to be decided as we enter
the latter half of this schedule once
again here are the parents Steve and
Zurich is board for for California
unicorns against our board one fadak
arowana Daniel nerd etske against Lenny
a Dominguez Wesley so against Gregorio
proned and Liam Lee against Darrow's
switz and so obviously a bit of a
mismatch there daro the board one for
the unicorns up against lammle who is
actually a high rate of player and board
for for us here I'm not sure what our
average team rating is but it's it's got
to be somewhere above twenty seven
hundred twenty seven fifty even oh yeah
that's that's what this calculation it's
really crazy it's in fact 2764 o or the
st. Louis Archbishop's that's not what
you want to be up against no matter who
who your team is that's that's I agree
with that I'm kind of curious what about
the Canada I want to say just bras yeah
the Canada chess pros well it obviously
depends on who they field week to week
but let me see if I could pull up their
their roster here so
and yeah I will mention our average
rating 2764 California's average rating
26:10 yes so that's a that's a 150 point
gap there for us which is it's nice to
see it's nice to see well it looks like
the chest bras have a couple 2700 so
that they can play each week but then
let's say they play Grichuk and firoozeh
but I thought they can't put off for
free jets at once they can get they can
get two at once so let's say you know
they get a couple of their best guys
Christian confer you should play that's
around a 27:40 average rating and then
they have to field a couple 26 fifties
or below so they're gonna end up right
around 2700 with their best team nothing
compared to the 2764 dominance that is
our starting and the games are finally
underway so we can take a look we don't
have any oh we do have moves awesome all
right so nerd this key against linear D
for you called it oh my
this is ends yeah d for followed by
Knight c3 not the most yeah this um if
I'm not mistaken this was the game the
bits were the last game of the classic
and a mass between gory Ashkenazi bingen
yeah I actually didn't see that at the
final game of course June when June
retains her title but I'm in Rapids she
was she won the tournament yeah it went
to tiebreaks yeah but yeah so here we
see this Knight cannot to be 5 early on
and that's let me play the awkward died
a 6 - the c7 square but this is still
all pretty much normal theory
considering yeah um it's very
interesting so we kind of have a very
normal position right now for black
because something like ideally you would
want to kick this night out and then
just try to push this pawn so I feel
like what Y should be starting to do
some stuff
you see fool yeah you definitely want to
get the the c-pawn out of the way of the
night because the night ending up back
on c3 in front of a pawn on c2 is just
slightly awkward you want to be able to
push this pawn forward without having
this night in the way so you do see you
see four immediately with the idea now
that after c6 the night will come back
to c3 and support the pollen rather than
getting its way that's like a brief look
as another game because I feel like this
is going get pretty solid and it will
take a while until we have it here on
our board one Bobbie and Steven Zurich
we have a show copan oh and let's see I
can never pronounce this neither can i I
just give him my best
um all right ah so you know how in
recent years this Italian with a for
have been very popular you know it's
been expanding with B for a name yeah so
now
Fabiana is doing anything simply I think
before yeah I really like this just
taking all this space over here well is
that is that apartment um take it are
you done I guess yeah I feel like Bishop
b5 you kind of have to take it's both
Bobby's blitzing out pretty fast so my
guess is is I mean is there's some
discovery like Oh what is what is there
to worry about here like Bishop takes a
four and then I don't know exactly what
what Bobby's plan is well first of all I
don't know those preparations yeah but
Bishop takes a for Bishop is least a
little kind of misplaced over there
because the bishop on a4 is not really
doing much it's like a slightly worse
Lopez yeah but the Fisher might drop
back to c2 and then I guess there is
this open a file for black but I'm not
sure exactly where all the compensation
comes from perhaps actually okay so
Bishop takes a for you capture this
Bishop yeah I mean takes a for maybe
Knight d4 is the idea I think queen d1
just taking taking this d3 poem by a
very powerful Knight in fact f2 might
actually come under some pressure and so
Stephen actually avoids these
complications and place Knight c4
instead alright
I feel like this game is going kind of
are we just have to be careful because
at deadlines that you just mentioned yet
now why CAC Chi wants to take on a poor
cuz Queenie for okay for night before
doesn't work anymore just Queen D done
seems like you can probably just play 96
yeah it's a pawn offering the Chinese
bishops
I'm starting to rewrite your know yeah a
king size also you would have ideas with
just 96 or maybe if you feel like it's
some D fives or F fives or just some
ideas well yes the knight recapturing on
d7 is actually pretty pretty much
telegraphing that Fabi wants to play f5
here he's removing the knight out of the
f6 squared to make room for this f5 push
which then I don't mean seven can can
support quite nicely of course generally
you want to probably counter this as
white by playing in the center so I
would expect to see the move Bishop e3
and maybe d4 to follow yeah I was also
thinking about a move such as maybe um
what about something like b5 now if
Bishop c5 now you can just take Knight
takes e5 um yeah probably uh why don't
just have to retreat with with something
like Knight d2 and I think white really
does want to play this move d4 as as
soon as possible here otherwise these
moves like f5 are gonna be a little bit
problematic yes alright I like this
let's leave without this and go check
see how are we doing with our White's
pieces yeah so a lot of tension in the
center here and of course Gregorio Pirin
is board to from Mizzou up against our
board three Leslie so and I do wanna
mention Grigory has been hot recently he
scored three and a half out of four the
last match that he played with a
performance rating well over 2800
so he's one to look out for in this
match here he's definitely a good player
but well so is we yes so so is Wesley
that's a very good point and what we
have here is a lot of tension in the
center both players occupying all four
central squares I feel like this is not
something that both players have done as
their home preparation because like in
this move just after ninety three just
to play d5 blacks spend about two good
minutes on half thinking about it
yeah Wesley does have a bit of a time
edge already and now Bishop g5 holds all
the tension in the center and creates
some threats of taking on d5 maybe
involving a Bishop III to follow and you
might see this f7 pawn coming to a
little bit of pressure yeah I'm kind of
also kind of thinking so this Bishop on
g7 it's not something that you're kind
of used to with Lopez especially yeah so
black kind of Lynch flinches first and
takes all the pawns in the center but
now this pressure on f6 might be
slightly awkward and in fact there seems
to be a tactic right rook takes eiated
threatens yeah you have to take on
anyone I guess yeah but then just Wesley
have something in mind for that well
it's gonna check it is check episode
wait it's just it's just check I'm sorry
so White's winning a piece I'm everybody
a grass Wesley's up a piece or take c8
wins the game game over
black resigns this Bishop is way to the
end of what Wesley's up a piece this
game what happened okay yeah that's a
knight takes f6 and rook takes the ADA
simple tactics um black kind of just Oh
worse I mean kind of blunder this knight
of sickness he takes d4 just isn't
playable Knight of sixes yeah I mean
like I couldn't make sense of it in my
head that this could just be when I
thought my critiques d1 and black is
doing okay but no this this move is just
check and there's there's no
else to be done arctic c8 or who's the
defender of the bishop and after Bishop
f6 Festus o is going to win this game
yeah seems about it all right well just
I think we can call that one yeah all
right well why don't we check out board
for this is actually the most
competitive matchup by rating that we're
going to see all day here their board
one against our board for and we still
have around a 60 point rating advantage
going into this one but what what
position do we have on the board here
this looks favorable for white yeah it
looks slightly more comfortable but I'm
kind of curious let's go over to opening
real quick cuz mm nothing as much as
happening at this point
sure so this is a very common opening oh
this is my opening nice um I mean I
played this with black as well and it
just feels so nice so that this men use
this much space so I guess it's this
little opening never mind makes sense
yeah but sorrow is still your slew
teammate yeah so you're five so you've
got two teammates in this game Liam Lee
and Archbishop and Darrow's roots a
Billiken I guess yeah but this like a
move such as so from what I understand
the idea is that if was wise you can try
to push on for like t4 okay take control
of center because after d4 black kinda
has to take I mean eventually when d4
happens because if not then black's pawn
structure would be pretty bad of course
so six pawn not yeah I do
so I see four is kind of trying to
prepare for that and this coin d3 seems
nice at the moment
but I mean couldn't I just do something
simple as yeah Bishop f4 takes the Queen
away and now d4 will follow exactly in
fact immediately yeah I knew kinda have
to take it because if not d5 is coming
up d takes e5 is coming up a lot of
things are coming up too many threats to
be yeah
so just take so you now White's
dominates the center and
um these pawns are kind of like it just
feels nice
yeah I don't think this has gone quite
the way that daro would have anticipated
I think so this is this e pawn in the
center supporting this night on f5 it is
really the key difference here you see
black's knight on b6 is significantly
worse than the white knight on on f5 oh
I see something I think maybe cheerful
ideas with Bishop come on oh yeah
dangerous stuff looks cool dangerous
right
so h4 maybe this 4 is preparing for a
bit of history taketake or t8 yes Bishop
a sure thing comes on the board
nice all right say one more trade and
after Queen e8 Queen g4 starts to make
some strats on the Kings side
Bishop takes f6 is immediately
threatening so you see King h8 and then
moves like Knight h6 seem playable which
is kind of scary kind of scary to see I
don't know if it does anything so
probably not not h6 but so these types
of threats in the position CA Queen
afore I think is preparing some knight
g7 ideas as well as simply Queen takes
e7 took to look out for yeah I think
it's okay thinking would it be a good
idea for whites to try to they bring out
the itch treat Bishop a little bit more
likes relocate then I don't put the
bishop on it five interesting I think I
mean I islands like like h5 and h6 seem
like a very natural plane as well you
have a lot of pressure on these dark
squares and if you can just thrust this
upon a couple squares more forward I
think blacks just gonna be gonna be
checkmated of course h5 black would
wouldn't want to capture that pretty
immediately so that's kind of the
barrier to overcome yeah I mean I really
like this idea of just keeping the
pressure and just improving your pieces
so I think he oh we have a result yeah
what's this oh dude did win that game of
course he was just up a clean Bishop
from the opening
yeah so as expected Leslie so gets us
off to a good start as I said my goal
for the team is to get at least three
points every round and so we're well on
our way to doing that yeah I like that
that is such a good goal all right let's
take another look at our board one yeah
of course this is very key game and this
is looking for Fabiano wait this net on
f4 looks very very powerful to my eyes
right yeah each three this oh wait a
second is is that playable maybe Queen -
Queen h4 is nasty so this is actually
what happens and if Queen III just you
three I guess it's there's some checks I
don't know how I feel about this is
little bits just up up PE song that's
not so good what happens I wonder if
this was just like a blunder from Fabi
he played creep quickly um yeah I mean
he's up five minutes I'll give him that
but the King can can run to the Queen
side now there's there's no perpetual I
guess you can play move like g6 to try
to open things up but the knight on D 2
actually defends this f3 pawn and yeah
there's some more checks and Fabi
captures upon that it gets a blunder I I
think why it's just winning here simply
yep you will you you didn't ask for
three out of four yeah yeah that's
that's true
that that's that's my goal I guess I
didn't expect that Bobby today wanted to
so the thing is this even though it's a
piece less it's not as easy as
the game here if it so seriously in this
case at least White's King is slightly
weak so there there is the potential for
for Steven to go wrong here especially
with little time on his clock well it's
objectively white as white is crushing
this is this is just over now the poppy
of course opens up the see file looks to
invade a little bit but I think you can
expect to win here for for the white or
the black for the white pieces as I said
yeah it's yeah work c1 makes the threat
but it's not so difficult to to parry
this one a queen the queen F to Wall
Street
maybe you should play Queen H wanna but
then Knight g3 and yeah I don't maybe we
should stop looking in this game I don't
like I don't like this game
what's going on with Meredith's key
against Linea Dominguez here this one
does not seem to be too much for okay no
pieces are hanging no pieces and the
whole divides up to minor pieces okay
they even have the same number of pawns
good I feel like this game um both
chance both sides that still have
realistic chances yeah I feel like if
anyone's gonna be favor to it it might
be black with the two bishops yeah the
bishops not totally use all the move
soon can I not take this simply shoot p2
or just take Bishop takes III check this
is wait yes that's just a winning king
and woman why do people keep blending
their stuff with checks if I don't
understand
I don't understand can't I just take on
d4 Bishop takes d5 Bishop III if King
III okay I guess five King well I think
this one is probably a draw right so
Bishop d4 Bishop d5 Bishop e3 let's say
King III huh
pawn takes d5 King day four and then
King d6 apply f4 and there's there's no
entrance for the
anywhere so instead we see this but now
I think Bishop b2 might might pick up a
pawn I'm not sure
oh and we have a little little hiccup
there in the stream so yeah as I said I
would have expected Bishop b2 there to
attack this a3 pawn but that's not what
we see instead king of these six is
lineage choice and I think this game is
probably looking to be a draw yeah it
seems like it - its I feel okay so the
problem is you can't really move the
bishop from f6 anywhere and at the same
time he doesn't really want to move the
knight so I have three anywhere so this
bishop and this Knight they're just
gonna tank there and you're also not
gonna really move your pawns as well
yeah of course you would love to play a
move like a 5 and f4 but it's it's
difficult to achieve especially this
Knight now landing on t4 where it kind
of pressures that f5 pawn
why don't we I think this one is looking
to be a draw your body's gonna go back
to flow beyond those yeah we can look at
poppies game I think Liam Leah's games
take a deep breath there might be some
pieces hankies yeah okay brace for
impact
Fabia's is still down a piece though it
looks like I'm not sure about this one I
think we see Wesley in the chat a little
bit it's also JJ's typing JJ another
Archbishop as well deep on the roster we
haven't seen him get a chance to play
yet but he's and Jibril's are dealing
with them of course big tournaments
happening over there I am to be to be
fair in my experience I did manage to
draw one game like this I was like a
queen and Bishop and bunch of pawns
agains I had a queen and bunch of pawns
yeah Queen and games are ernit aureus ly
difficult to figure out especially in
situations like this where Steven is
down to his final seconds on the clock
and there are a number of weak pawns
position right you can imagine if this a
to pawn Falls it'd be very very
conceivable for black to win this game
yeah with this pawn on a to being so
strong so now you're gonna take on f3 I
want to say yes so you might play Queen
a1 but then you can take on g4 so I
think you do have to capture capture f3
right now and then okay so he gives a
check first and now takes takes the f3
pawn and this one is is going to look
look to be a loss yeah I mean so put
some checks yeah there's still plenty of
checks to to go around but eventually
how does white want to win this game
well I feel like what I really want as
why that was really wants to try and try
to activate my pieces it's like the King
on g4 I kind of like it even though it
looks a little awkward but then at the
same time that Knights coming to
something like efore yeah you force
seems like a great square for this night
my question is so I guess Bobby can't
play something like Queen B 2 because 3
C 4 would defend the pawn on a to
inactivate although we do see him play
it so there goes everything I just said
but well it's very dangerous
oh wow f6 is a huge commitment from from
Steve Queen g6 I'm just sick of 6 ball
at least of all if you don't want to
open up your king too much I'm sorry
Diplo what what I'm so sorry I just
thought the Queen was on B wanna whoops
you're skipping diagonals a little bit
good news is every trade of pawns get
spa be closer to I guess a drawn endgame
although now Stephen is looking to just
I think outright checkmate this black
King here he is allowing some more
checks though things like Queen e2 and
Queen g2 are both playable tamiya is
that I think I would play just a simple
between g2 here Wow
efore is is some bravery either our
hearts work
is their challenge here why are some
people saying okay why is so Leslie
saying draw a line is it the drill it
might be a draw I don't know it's I
would assume that black gets checkmated
somehow it seems like it
this Queen G to move seems right you do
want to be a bunch of checks as white
might be doing well as black sorry it's
so notable you really can't trade the
Queen's here and you also can't take a
to do the checkmate
ah there's Queen d8 check I suppose
queen F to check as well
oh and now III maybe III oh you're
looking our --fill yeah yeah it's black
winning III wins the game wait you three
just wins III you trade Queens and then
you make up what's Bobby what's what's
III won the game that there's nothing to
miss well what is how oh my god
Wesley so agrees with me I'm not making
it up 3-1 again what is happening this
feels kind of wrong how did what happens
oh my God he's getting checkmated oh no
it's checkmate
Oh Bobby why uh that was unbelief how
does he miss III here
how does he miss right alright let's
let's let's take a look at what does he
miss key resource check that's triple
tacos let's okay I'll come back Nick
Wesley so agrees with me I trust that
guy so yeah Queen at five is where we
need it back up to so forward a bit so
Queen uh five simply III here and black
is cleaning by force the White Queen is
pinned to the King so it can't move the
knight might come back to e4 but then
we'll simply trade Queens push e to and
I want Sun stops so huge missed
opportunity for Fabiano carrot one in
there but before we talk about that too
much there's one game left in play and
that is between Lee
did you say this game wasn't a draw yes
as expected this this game not amounting
to much but Lee and Lee is playing daro
and they're in some severe time
lightheaded Wow all right okay
let's focus on this game Dorsett take a
deep breath
so c6 is hanging okay uh and it's not
going anywhere
so what pawn structure is king I like
Roy white I like the bishop pair I like
the pawn structure I just kind of the
gun safety is a little bit yeah a little
bit off hopefully that the White King
can find some shelter on the light
squares but this night the things that
just cease doing good job
the e3 square so yeah h1 the only safe
square for this King right now I just
handed hmm d'argo down to 5 seconds
though I I really don't want to have
hanging pieces so maybe maybe so just
taking and white is now just up to clean
upon this looks like a win again game to
me I think we Emily should should be
able to pull this one out he does now
it's like I mean like ten more seconds
yet I mean it about 10 seconds is very
relevant here ya are playing exclusively
on the increment right now so ya know
why it simply improves this king I
really don't I expect to see a move like
g4 yeah and then if I've come onto the
board pretty question before is a pretty
clean move it restricts the knight now
Gina bf5 slow and yeah first first I
like a 4 is okay just covering all the
bases on the Queen's side keeping this
night under control and then expect to
see g5 and h6 and this game will be
going in our direction this names like
it's alright so improving this Bishop to
c4 very professional stuff freeing the
king racing all the way in and now
actually even king g6 is is coming onto
the board oh wow
ideally mystics would have came to the
game yeah why it might be just trapping
this night now I think
yeah bishop before this yeah where's
King g4 but okay night the game's over
all right well I mean we attack any wind
we can yeah I cannot believe I missed
that bet
III move so that brings our score after
this first round here it's a two and a
half to one and a half and our favorite
not quite making my 3-point Bowl but I'm
sure we can make that up in the later
rounds yeah it was a pretty tense match
I I mean let's be realistic father's
game it's not so easy to like be losing
constantly for so many moves and then
just like finding that idea yeah but he
paused he paused on the move
he was looking he was still so why don't
we actually check out the results here I
think we have a little graphic to show
it Stephen Zurich upsets our board one
world class Tata Steel champion Fabiano
Kara wanna Daniel nerd Itsuki drawers
Lenny a Dominguez and actually our
boards three and four are both the
winners in this round taking Algren
choreo proned and Liam Lee no wait
hanger Corey Oberon and Darrow's Suites
though the winners being Wesley so in
and Liam Lee so that brings the score to
two and a half to one and a half in our
favor off to kind of a good start in
most cases a little bit of a rocky start
for for Fabia
but I mean missed opportunities for sure
as long as he kisses the spirit up and
finds III the next times we're happy
yeah you shake that one off you laugh
about it but you're still doing well it
makes for great tactics oh it does III
what would have been a very very nice
move I feel like if you shot that
position you know like a tactic book
everybody would immediately find it
because they knew like they're looking
for something
look I'm no Fabiano carry one and I saw
III okay like this this was not a
difficult move defense rests
Bobby Bobby has to
has to be shaking his head about that
one with that in mind though let's look
look to the next round with higher hopes
and see who who is paired against to
Darras words has his chance against
Wesley so Stevens irk moves on to play
Lee Emily Bobby Kara Juana is paired up
against Daniel Meredith ski and Lenny a
Dominguez is playing daro wits in this
round to which I don't know if I believe
these pairings but they might be true
let me actually double check the process
here they're all gonna plate so they're
eventually they're all gonna play each
other everybody plays everybody in these
matchups but yeah so those were not
quite the correct Hanks in my off the
top of my head I believe Bobby now plays
their board 3 da replace our board 3s
that would be Fabi up against Daniel
Meredith ski E and daro up against ya
Wesley so yes and board to plays board
for so that's what that's plenty a
Dominguez against here they are so I can
stop trying so hard
Bobby Cara wanna plays Daniel Daniel NAR
dead ski Lenny Dominguez against
Stephens York Wesley so against our
Suites and Liam Lee against gregorian
and you do see the average ratings there
2764 against 26:10 once again we're
favored and all 16 matchups here looking
to get a big score like I said my goal
for each round three out of four but now
we need we need a three and a half to
make up for this round one round one
blip here can't be dropping games land
like that against especially against
Stephen Zurich who is a very very strong
player but is they're at their lowest
rated player in this matchup
yeah I agree with that um but to be fair
for example this last the arm the game
against are you so our board for in
their board one right it seemed like the
end game should have been ended in a
draw probably is
but before he lost tonight okay and
probably like before he went for the
before oh yeah of course here like it
feels kind of white has better chances
but realistically this shouldn't be such
a easy win right so anything can happen
though especially in these days yes daro
only 10 seconds to play this position
and white definitely has some pressure
here with the bishops it's tough to find
a good home for that night and then I
think the key mistake happened a few
moves later we saw black play Bishop e6
six change these bishops off so you see
after Bishop d7 56 is simply losing a
pawn but black really felt the pressure
of the bishops and thought he needed to
to trade one of them off and this hasty
decision with no time on the clock is
what gave Liam Lee his chance and and he
he certainly didn't miss it
yeah but okay you are really hurt by
that game I you I trusted him I try I
saw III I was so proud of myself I
thought well father's gonna win like I
saw it Bobby and go get him and then he
just he didn't do it will come back will
come back yeah it's definitely not
something you want to remember [ __ ] me
buddy no no I'm sure he'll he'll score
three points the next three rounds to
make up for it I trust him okay but yeah
we're just waiting for word round two to
get underway here then giving the
players a moment to rest I suppose while
we get everything set up once again here
are the current standings in the Western
Division you see the Canada chess bras
topping the leaderboard with the st.
Louis Archbishop's close behind and the
reason for that the chest brows and the
Archbishop's that actually all both won
all their their matches so far but the
tres pearls have one there's by a little
bit of a higher margin than us so they
get five and a half extra points and
they're there three matches and that's
why you see there their lead in the
Western Division notably they also have
a slightly higher average performance
rating so they deserve to be up there
for now but come next week that's when
we get our shot at playing the
despero's and if we take them down we
will be soaring into first place in the
Western Division so that that is the
goal you do see here the schedule for
next week mark your calendars 12 p.m.
Central Time 10:00 a.m. Pacific time is
when our match against the kings of
chess bras will take place and that'll
be one for the ages possibly to decide
the Western Division champion yeah I
can't wait to see how that's one of
those it's yeah it's definite I think
that's that's definitely the game that's
we're all gonna be waiting for but fun
fact according to my last information
Pan Am's is going to be happening next I
mean this Christmas this is coming
Christmas in Canada also very
interesting yeah some people will have
trouble traveling yeah tough to get all
the passports yeah maybe but yeah the
Canada chest bras doing a lot for chess
in Canada the chess bras are and it'll
be interesting to see if they manage to
make it to that the playoffs is as well
it looks like their chances are good but
we'll be certainly be finding them for
that number one position here in the
Western Division as always you guys can
join us on YouTube where we're keeping
an eye on the chat here if you guys have
any questions for us we can get back to
you on those but you can also follow the
games live on chess comm you just want
to find chess comm / TV and then click
on the archbishop's and that's where you
can find the games for yourself so there
you see chess TV just give it a click
and once you're on chess comm / TV
scroll down just a bit click on the
archbishop's and you will be following
all four of our players here
with that of Mines we're looking into
round two here where of course favored
on all four boards as we will be for all
four of these rounds and hoping to score
some points
yeah this is nuts
okay this is not helping I'm still
looking at the game between why don't we
check out this game between Dominguez
yeah we missed tell me got to this
jarana
and again we look that's we briefly look
that their openings it is interesting 93
to b5 idea simply night before that the
center kind of gets blown up and I guess
we just saw some piece trades yeah this
is like such a normal taking over the
center and everything seems very very
logical this hope game was really
logical yeah yeah I mean take
terrifically black could just try and
take this night here and just bring in
the canyons so you open it well Bishop
f3 might might actually be an
interesting idea here right can you take
f3 and then take H
f4 kind of yeah there's that for but
mini I just II five is pretty much even
time ah disaster if the king was a
little bit farther yeah so there's no
time to take f3 and take H - but the Sun
game does disappear to just be drawn
yeah I completely agree I mean there is
not much chance for either of the
players to make a serious mistake per se
so this just feels very logical yeah
just a just a natural chess game the
natural result of chess of course it's
very cool the night on e - we should be
talking C - you can't take on a tree
King bee tree yeah King d3 but Raptor
so Bishop back to e5 and then I solve it
I think that's how yeah so there was a
question in the YouTube chat about
Darrow's game in particular you
mentioned this is the line that you play
against the English he was asking what
line that is I guess we don't have that
game ok uh I mean I remember like c-45
yeah so yeah c-45 and like expands in
the center
yeah so the idea is that you'll have
your you place e4 e5 and then you play
in out of 65 and after CD 595 as soon as
the bishop is on g2 you just play 96 to
avoid any kind of like discovery yeah
and then you'll want to have your knight
on c6 two bishops on e7 e six and
sometimes upon f6 depending on how white
goes about it sometimes they play like
d3 a trees and we have a new game
happening yes so of course stars game
perhaps not the best example of how to
play this position is like this white
ended up with a little bit of an edge
that's yeah you just expand in the
center early on try to take some space
right here we have round two getting
started so we have fabi's game maybe
again this is not Ischia and it's
another Roy Lopez everybody loves the
Roy Lopez so black place e5 white
expands in the center and now d5
actually closes off the center this is
fabi's choice
this Knight comes in to c4 and now a for
taking some space on the queenside
challenging this a6 b5 structure for for
Danya
oh it waiting we callin Danya Danya or
Daniel or Naro or nerd it's coming wait
your turn sorrow
Nardo yeah yeah he goes by Danya as well
I think cut him maybe I made that up I
think he goes by Danya this is actually
kind of funny the first time in
Catherine masters he didn't know where I
was from instead speaking Russian I mean
I was like know what yeah and I mean
it's it's probably a good bet if you
don't know we're a chess players from
you just just start speaking Russian and
they know at least few words yeah so
yeah we actually see Fabio playing very
very quickly
he's actually got 10 more seconds than
he started with which is very impressive
but just a two-second increment and he
is expanded on the queenside
yeah well I think something that's you
have to be mindful of is these be fours
cuz if before is kind of closing
everything off so you like whoops no I'm
just saying like if c4 yeah you
definitely don't want to take this you
also don't want to keep it just like
this thank you so yeah p4 is is played
yeah everything is just gonna happen in
the king-size so sometimes I'm if four
is gonna come up soon or size fives I
guess the question is does the closing
of Queen side favor white or black here
because both players now looking to play
on the Kings side that was just answer
your question it's a question of who's
faster right yeah g4 is yeah paralyzing
the ideas with f5 for black now you're
gonna move that night then you get the
night g4 so I could come to f4 or maybe
even the g7 square where it can kind of
support that five push I think I don't
like this move Knight g7 I think this is
is a nice idea to support f5
and then I'm not sure how white wants to
really deal with it okay so not a four
instead and to my eyes I would I
wouldn't want to capture capture this
you don't to take this thing I want to
taking place by five and then enjoy my
open diagonal and I going to forgot
about Aoife but let's see those if I
actually work maybe not due to the fact
that you can take this pause and then uh
yeah Bishop Bishop f6 would be the
problem I'm trying to just think though
if Knight takes D seven is anything
UNITA fits Bishop c3 Lukey yes yeah so
there's some complicated tactics to be
calculated here which is probably why
Fabia's is pausing yeah really if if a
five is working then you should take
this night and if not you should
probably let the night stand on that for
I think do you agree here yeah I agree
that's my statement and if you want to
keep them well you don't want to keep
the night on that fool okay
so so he captures and does not actually
go for a five and instead of sacrificing
the exchange here which Tonya
immediately captures wasting no time
thinking about it and white definitely
will have plenty of compensation here
there are not a ton of open files on the
board and if Bobby can launch an attack
on the king it's it's going to be well
worth it well the question is how are
you gonna get that attack are you gonna
start it like H or H four I think is a
natural way to start and if H five I
guess g5 might be the other thing to
look out for but I mean if I'm Fabi
Carolina I'm considering capturing on g5
if a pawn lands there
let's look at another girl getting
nervous again yeah I like my blood
pressure it's alright so how many years
yeah Lenny a doing on board to Chris
Stevens York the only unicorn to
successfully win against the
Archbishop's in the first round here the
taking out Bobby Cara wanna and so now
he has the black pieces against Lenny a
and he chooses the French defense this
is not a line I'm I'm super familiar
with here so what captures on c5 early
early on yeah I feel like this is some
one of those stuff that's you do in
blitz games a lot I see mainly because
you want to up about prepare your
opponents okay and so it does get
developed black captures on c3 and now
the white structure is a little bit
fractured but I guess scene still has
this pawn on e5 really pressuring of the
black Kings side as well as the the
center yeah these CC pawns it does give
you the opportunity to play c4 a little
bit more freely um another thing to
think about is so in specially in French
this this square is very weak so okay
ideally you would want to have a nice
here right just because it's control so
mean square is you get a chance to maybe
you could run wild with your F pawn so
see ideas of 94 ideas about for
certainly to follow and I think a couple
more moves have been played oh we saw
Ricky one for white defending this upon
perhaps preparing to move this night and
then this trade on d3
white takes back with the Queen to
defend the c3 pawn and now Queen c4
black really looking to to make some
more trades of course white does not
want to capture this Queen yes if you do
so you get black the d5 square and you
you can your your C pawns down also
something like if you exchange the
Queen's on c4 the bishop on C it gets to
be free to either with Bishop b6 Bishop
e7 or Bishop d7 Bishop c6 exact
so instead black makes the trade on g3
fixes the white pawn structure but
remove some of these these terrifying
threats of a devastating attack use it
using that Queen and now how do you free
the black pieces here because it looks
to my eyes like it just has some some
more natural squares for the pieces for
example black can't castle here and due
to the hanging knight on a 7 and this
black Bishop is going to be looking for
a diagonal maybe it will choose a 6 to
f1 but it'll certainly be difficult to
find the best squares for these puzzles
I really want that light on d6 yeah d6
would be great you could you can try to
play 94 so I was thinking that but if
Bishop a6 them how would you progress I
think something like Rickey 3 and then
f4 and f5 might be the idea that that's
the plane that I could come up with off
the top of my head and then uh what do
you have to come you kind of have to be
careful what's pressures on c3 yes stuff
like Erick c8 might come yeah certainly
something to look out for I'm not sure
exactly I don't know what I want to do
with my c3 and d3 pawns and I think
that's the key decision that that Lenny
a has to make here
you could play d4 that that really looks
looks bad to my eyes you don't want to
give black total control on the C voice
yeah but if you play c4 instead then
maybe you're just opening things up for
for black favorably so it's a difficult
decision to be made
maybe he just wants to leave these pawns
were they where they're at but then you
know as you said they can become targets
the bishop on a6 would hit the pawn on
d3
you can bring it up to C 8/10 opponents
e3 certainly nothing is nothing is
simple here for Lenny a that's so
interesting that being said though I
think I do like White's position me too
few more games going on just a little
bit let's let's take a brief look at
what do we have here yeah this looks
like a Wesley so again
and this ePHI phone might be falling it
seems difficult to defend the white
rooks might be invading along the D file
but certainly this epon looking a little
bit isolated oh this is a Berlin isn't
it it looks like a Berlin yeah but but I
mean it's it's a more interesting Berlin
than than normal right I think like
certainly has an edge here
b5 is is going to fall okay I'll give
you that yeah I thought you were seeing
so many brilliance why I thought you
were gonna say and saying interesting
Berlin is like an oxymoron er but okay
so Rick d5 would defend the epon but
then I was thinking maybe this trick he8
is good enough for black hair to add
some more pressure to this poem and
there there's no defenders left I really
don't like that I mean we're black I
like what for wise I really think that
night on e 2 needs to be in a better
place this is slight white just had like
one or two extra Tempe to put this night
on f5 its position will just be for is
good don't have to be too fancy but
before I like from f5 the fact that I
was hitting the bishop as as well as age
six but he forgives gives Y plenty of
options as well things like Knight f6
would start to be the ideas Oh
so we do see an H III but now I think
this pawn is is Wesley's for the taking
Bishop takes e5 why not just have shoot
yeah cuz if Knights then you don't want
to have pins on stuff don't want to pin
yourself yeah so we do see if I should
take sono f3 defends this con on g4 and
things are not totally trivial for it
for Wesley here white does still have
total control over this D file and we'll
have to find a home for the Knights
but if Wesley can kind of consolidate
and solve some of these problems he will
just be a pawn up and a little unclear
if it's enough to try to win the game
but it will certainly be
Wesley's Wesley's game to win no risk
here I think for for other the u.s.
player
Lesly so these are I've got this is mmm
it's most likely going to end in a draw
what I think I agree with that statement
but it's it's definitely an interesting
game because both white and black have
some weaknesses that if they're not
careful it could go pretty wrong yeah I
think knight c6 might be a really good
move for well I like that a lot too but
then 9 is 5 yeah not a 5 I wanted to
play h5 the second you move this Knight
from g3 and that's why I think things
are maybe a little bit more awkward for
daro here if you planned out of 5 I can
play h5 solving the weakness and if you
don't 94 is going to come and then b3 is
a very very big pawn and this night is
just blocking out every every rook every
rock in the white position so some
definite decisions have to be made here
Wesley is taking his time I think he's
trying to find the best way to press for
a knight yeah let's go look at another
game I feel I'm good feeling about this
one yes so the last game we haven't
looked at yet is Grigori oprand against
Lee Anne we of course Lee Anne Lee our
board for still well over 2700 and has
been for a while one to look out for ah
quick question JJ is very active here is
he also has active over there what do
you mean like he's very active
especially like on our games well he's
guessing the most yeah he's not in the
YouTube chat but I think he is following
on on chess calm okay so here liam Lee
seems to be up a full night I don't know
how that happened but I like his chances
we were not complaining the second game
that we've seen from Jorge where
unfortunately he's just gone down a
piece so this is the position that's he
still had the piece and then BOOM before
it takes to pieces at the same time is
that what happened yeah oh well it's
kind of went wrong over here okay
yeah this should be fun this is Linda
terrible but then Rick takes c5 queen d6
the text - yeah this is and then after
you're okay five Queen Queen c3 or queen
before it is yeah the game that's that's
really unfortunate for the car he had
the same didn't he get into sort of
similar problems yeah he just hung a
piece - it's a similar tap well not a
similar tactic but - a few of you moves
long combination - Wesley so we're not
complaining of all the pieces
yeah we're dropping some points here
rather unfortunate but good news for for
these Archbishop's and so yeah
definitely if there are any definitely
expect liam lee to be able to win this
game up a full piece yeah Rick be
Deanna's now threatening to trade off
even more with move Queen takes see one
followed by ripped d1 check and then the
fewer pieces on the board the the more
blacks extra piece will begin to shine
and this is this is looking fairly
hopeless I think for for Grigory so
definitely expecting a win here alright
now that we've seen all the games as
we're which one in particular do you
want to kind of focus on jump back to
let's take another look at Bobby Knight
its key cuz I feel like their disc is a
very logical player so that could be
interesting
absolutely I like White's position it's
feels more in control waste of all yet 9
h5 is threatening this f6 square I mean
even though you were like ah it's a
still of an exchange and down like okay
so put it this way White has a knight
and upon uh
400 rope fit he sacrificed right all
right that's that's a good way to put us
yeah so upon for the rope yeah but it
looks like f6 is is falling so he's
going to get a second pot yeah it's very
very important but nice black solutions
just so bad
doesn't gonna go with like all tangled
up so terrible so I believe Lee painful
to have to play oh yeah no yeah no sign
of Florida roguish six and at least f8
maybe this causing some problems I don't
know I will say that what what I wanted
to mention here is that it's important
that white spawns are so relevant there
there are too strong Center pawns that
that white has sometimes you'll see a
player give up the exchange for a couple
pawns in a piece and the the two poems
really aren't relevant they're like on
a2 and b2 and yes unless they're they're
actually a part of the game acting as a
piece acting as attackers you saw this
right now so that's why black wouldn't
simply play h6 and defend the g5 fun
that's exactly right
in fact you might see e5 anyways giving
up a second exchange first like rookie
fat check well i think i think ii 5 is
is winning a rug all mostly mistaken the
f5 e 5 what does black play my take self
I've checked pawn fo rook age 66 check
seems powerful right yeah but I don't
know is it this is a good dress sock
fish doesn't like ki5 thank you well it
likes it it's plus two plus two and a
half going on past three but there are
better moves here for for white simply
simply taking on as nobody finds the
best I'm the best okay maybe rigged up
to this lately no e fives the best move
I'm the best like five so play the tax
Go Go
then eight don't fail me now okay any
any movie yeah if you have like multiple
moves that are all good and winning you
should walk happy and I love seeing I
love seeing it oh look at those ons oh
god it's gorgeous
God what I'm putting doubts on my
intense insane endgame class tomorrow
they know this is this is three like eat
oh my god I can't I can't even talk
about how good these phones are this is
why you play chess does it make up for
the fact the treet I forgiven him I have
this work on h6 literally cannot like
move without this beta cap seriously I
move d6 now is very very simple kingi
for domination g-force to Bishop c4 so
none of the box thank you
total domination by Fabiana care wanna
care this is I have this man very proud
of him that he's playing so beautifully
after last round and I mean Black has
nothing to do black has to play this
move King FA just shuffle his pieces now
if I'm white I'm playing king e4 I'm
getting all my pieces into the perfect
positions then I'm playing d6 King d5
and you really see how the minor pieces
are absolutely dominating blacks entire
position here even a move F sixes is
also totally winning any path you want
to take for this King I want I want to
start with d6 I like f6 it keeps this
room suffering even
more in a box neck right now d6 maybe
came out live as well yeah I mean you
can take g5 yeah resignation is really
nice I really like these they're so nice
this I can't
I and there's I mean I I can't that's an
incredible game from Fabiana Carolina
love to see that one especially after
the disaster that happened in round one
which I've already forgotten about after
seeing this what happened I mean I don't
all I remember is Fabi played this
beautiful game where he got a 5d five at
five the players couldn't move they were
helpless against the minor pieces
what a beautiful game for Fabiana
Carolina yeah I think so that brings our
scored a three and a half to one and a
half and we also expect Liam Lee to win
his games a couple of the games let's
just see how this is going yep still up
a piece clean piece up three and a half
minutes
grigory's out of time and running out
now just resignation great that's two
points in this round two
there's still a couple games left let's
look at I think Wesley Zoe's game
castara was down to his final seconds
once again so here Wesley has the black
pieces we liked his position a little
bit earlier on but we were saying it
might just be a draw and now on this
King and pawn in game I think that holds
true really no no path of entry for for
the black King here or the way it came
yeah I think this is I think this game
is like can't even
I completely agree with everything you
said so it's it's going to take a
miracle like a super blunder for some
science to for the result to be anything
go to draw yeah I mean blacks only way
of gaining entry is kind of to play the
move g4 but white can just respond f/4
yeah and if black wants to invade with
this King and he'll be leaving behind a
protected passed pawn which which you
really can't do so this game should be a
draw only other game going on still is
lenio Dominguez this game against
Stevens ear and why don't we we check
out what's happening there I
great let's see so why are you taking
his time you're trying to find the right
move and rook c5 is his choice so it
looks like white is up on this was that
French that we mentioned earlier and
yeah after this bishop I guess we'll
have to move maybe white is aiming to
play something like c4 but yeah maybe
maybe you can't do it right away so
maybe he'll expand on the king of site
first oh wow so the work simply comes to
c2 and this is the endgame that the
players have chosen to go for I'm not so
sure about this one maybe every size
here looks dangerous right yeah
what about simple you just move linear
loop okay so he goes for King f3 and now
both players have four pawns but yeah
this f5 move I think is really powerful
you're getting a pawn to e6 by force and
it looks quite difficult to really deal
with this if you're playing with black
hair black king is kind of really really
cut off and the other side of the board
exactly so you have a couple options
with black you can take f5 but then
white will play e6 or you can take a
five but then white will play F takes G
six
either way this pawn is is getting to
the e6 square and was upon so far
advanced you need something very very
concrete to be able to keep it under
control so what is Stephens idea to stop
this pawn you can play rook h1 to try
and get to the pawn or yeah rook h4 is
also you also stop with d5 ideas yeah
but now rook c8 and d5 will come to
protect this pawn I mean the question
for black is if he can get his King back
into the game
Rick g8 is playable though now yeah
interesting you just pick up all those
fun pawns
yeah you pick up some pawns and
hopefully you can actually play a move
c4 next I think this is
the way to to continue the game I think
c4 would be kind of powerful you the
rook can't be drawn away
oh okay so he just captures instead oh
now this check what about he's seven
right yeah
d6 the newark d8 and the game's over
this isn't winning this is just winning
d6 he's unstoppable rook da and then
Ricky eight yes is gonna be a queen and
the game's over so that's a win for
Lenny a dominguez and I will say Wesley
and ro did officially draw that game and
now we see resignation okay I'm Steven
Zurich so I wanted to average three
points per round and first round we only
got two and a half in this round we got
three and a half made up for it I also
wanted to mention that's what is our
total point pass so we are up to six
points against there are two points
after two rounds yeah so we only it's
only two more points to win the whole
match well two times one half gonna have
to win of course eight and a half is the
magic number
once we've reached that threshold we
will be given an extra bonus
ten points for winning the match and
that will go on to our score in the
division well with this conclusion to
round two dorsal why don't we take a
quick break for some round three
coverage see you again when you visit
st. Louis you'll probably want to watch
the Cardinals for the Blues what about
after the game heading back to the hotel
would be a major error instead boogie
through the city and discover the music
that gave the Blues their name at the
National Blues Museum Broadway Oyster
Bar or even the legendary blueberry
so whether you love the Cardinals the
Blues or the Blues come play with us you
guys know I can't play this right st.
Loup is always exploring be surprised be
intrigued be delighted the world chess
Hall of Fame in st. Louis is nothing
you'd expect and everything you love
three galleries highlight the history
culture and creativity behind the game
explore chess in ways you never imagined
it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
world-class art play together the world
chess Hall of Fame mind art experience
we get your autograph yeah of course I
think it's pretty cool that you love
chess so much we love chess too I just
just program and gotta meet a real-life
Grandmaster I got this big one time I
put a police captain after school and
took my name in 27 moves Wow
I should be asking for your autographs
check out all chess has to offer at st.
Louis chess club org
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right hello and welcome back to
round three against the California
unicorns the games have already got
underway so very quickly I just want to
walk you through the pairings here
kori Oberon is up against our board one
Bobby Cara wanna Darrow's Suites take
some money a Dominguez Wesley so is up
against Stephen Zurich and Liam Lee
against Daniel nard it's key and with
that in mind why don't we check out the
game story I agree
I stole your mouse it's okay let's see
so what are we looking at here on board
one with 500 poor old brain blunder to
pieces so far yes but in this case what
on this planet is happening I want to
say something's jobs preparations
alright let's see uh normal stuff I've
seen these before nothing too weird okay
getting there ah I don't know your
screen trap yeah I guess this is the
idea that the White Queen will have
nowhere to go but I'm not so sure this
is a favorable thing for Fabi the two
rooks in this case might end up being
being worth a bit more especially if you
see move like like a three or yeah as we
see in the game I think Brooke Brooke
could be one come onto the board Oh rip
e1 is not yet played but Rick me what I
think could be powerful the idea being
you play move like ninety seven the
Queen takes on f8 and then this Bishop
has simply nowhere to go everyone was
just plate um I think Bobby might what
it's funny losing Bobby might be losing
[Music]
lets us think about the good stuff that
they only need two and a half points you
have points eight games to win the match
I mean I think we're winning the match
we're favored and all remaining eight
games except maybe this one now I think
this one
it's looking a little bit a little bit
off
perhaps some some home prep
grigory is pulling out here against the
world number tune chess player yeah
let's take another look at the other yes
you see fabio souza um is this bishop
now Bishop takes c5 now when you just
take back ninety seven and you're done
it's two rooks and the piece again yeah
with with two powerful bishops this
should be very very good for for white
here that being said you know Fabia's
had chances before and hopefully he can
you can find some practical play here to
try and challenge Grigory but okay let's
let's move on with the greener pastures
how is Sebastian doing aka money a
domingus up against our roots here and
it's this is also a crazy position my a
my goodness hmm let's see
ah special of course lenio Dominguez is
chess calm user for those case what I'm
trying to figure out is well the just by
looking at right now it feels very like
I kind of would prefer to be why it's
honestly yeah white has a little bit
extra space and this control of the D
file is as useful as well so this pawn
structures are usually set to be better
I mean it takes a very like a lot of
skills to be able to actually make
something out of it but just looking at
it these pawn structures cuz this like
this for against these tree whereas
these for against these tree is you know
it's a little bit tougher to immobilize
your pawn majority right the pawns on
the Kings side in the center you can
play g3 in f4 and f5 whereas on the
Queen side the three pawns are usually
enough to stop the for ponts and the
specific structure will move like c4 for
example kind of locks the black pawn on
to see
five it can be difficult to break free
with that of mine though it's not all
bad for black here like g5 and your king
will have a nice g7 square you keep an
eye on f4 the nice on e sticks is
extremely strong because it's it's
controlling pretty much all of the
important squares d4 for just blocking
the that bishops eye mmm it's such a it
should be I mean what I'm trying to say
is that that night there is really good
yeah so actually I think g6 is a little
bit more of an actually yeah I want to
get this King off the back rank so you
can bring her up to the defy Alta to
challenge the White Rose please
I I do like the idea of g6 instead of
something more active like g5 because
sometimes I have nice III and I have 5
you you would prefer to deal with
something less um acne for your
opponents definitely so that being said
I think white doesn't just stop King G
seven years so the way I would want to
do that is by playing rook d7 I'm not
sure what Lenny Jay actually has in mind
any same play Bishop g5
yeah Bishop e5 I guess is a playable
move but you might run into some trouble
maybe just like g3 from white and
already this Bishop is looking a little
bit stuck so I don't think it's totally
easy here for black to completely
equalized which would be done by it by
getting a rook to d8 and then after some
trades I think like really doesn't have
any any problems but with them we rook
d7 I think it could be difficult sorry
that's what I expect ro to play here
other ideas for for black might be
trying to kick out this rook on d7 using
the night somehow specifically like a
move like King e8 could be it'd be
interesting of course ninety-four
becomes a threat so Knight g3 going for
a four square okay I want I simply want
to play King King g7 year my angry you
can't just tell anybody 457 I you simply
can't play drifty aids
yeah D 748 and you can't take the bishop
due to the pen along the D file and I
think by trading off some of these rooks
black is really getting a lot closer to
total consolidation meaning you won't
have any any real problems in that
endgame so looking I think equal ish or
Lenny a why don't we check out Wesley so
is game against Stephens York one looks
complex black is attempting to win a
piece but I think white might be
responding in kind with a move like c3
to challenge the black knights
although wait a second that doesn't see
just say that four is is Wesley losing a
piece oh god it's all falling apart
dorsa people keep your pieces
alright let's see here yeah is this
where it started to go wrong so Bishop
takes d4 good night ah this is okay oops
so this just looks like a bad tactic I
guess yeah cuz just take on d4 wait a
second I'm very very very confused why
not 96 after Bishop takes d4 this must
have been the original intention right I
guess there's this move Knight takes III
that's the problem
yeah but right 96 must have been
Wesley's idea yeah and defend this pawn
tactically but after 96 Knight takes III
and you don't have time to capture the
black Queen because black will capture
the white queen and you don't have the
ability to take back all three because
then what I was trying to sink us can't
you just um take with the F mind the
pawn and isn't that still pretty decent
yeah I think maybe that that would be
equalizing and maybe even why not g4
here that the same tactic just with
colors reversed I'm not sure can you
check if like because this seems like a
such a reasonable move just taking with
the other night
yeah night night have takes d5 ideal but
for white g4 as well would have been
within maybe equalizing but now we have
this awkward positioning of the Knights
where it's gonna be difficult for for
white to save it yeah just queen g4 Ken
I mean King is eight should be I want to
say enough yeah moves like like H five
as well moves like Knight G 7000 96
these all are going to to give Steven an
extra piece so interesting that I mean
Stevens York is really pulling on all
the services for some reason our top
players are struggling against Steven uh
somehow he's making very simple mistakes
stuff that they shouldn't be doing think
as another game how's Liam Lee doing it
against Daniel Meredith thing Lee seems
okay he stands he's not hanging any
pieces which is okay good great news
great if you like from now on never be
open a new game of the Cape he says yeah
I'm just counting the pieces just
counting the pieces making sure um let's
see so in this situation
I'm trying to figure out what would be
whites ideal like treads yeah
wait a second does this what how does
this work can I not just take this night
I guess black is playing d5 know what is
tape but the night takes d6 I'm slightly
confused oh he's going for special but
does this work
I mean perpetual if it does work it's it
is a perpetual uh okay I guess I do have
to take the rook otherwise your gauge
three is it's going to be a powerful
idea yeah um although maybe I can I
don't know interesting tactics from from
Naro here what if I play f3 Oak Street
sorry King f2 and now both of your looks
are hanging we shouldn't be five No
I don't know dangerous tactics to be
sure that's why I'm Lee I think is we
don't have a results however not the
nothing good result so Fabiana did close
this game it was a I mean if he came
pretty much came out of the open and
lost so yeah somehow good gray tricked
Fabi into some some home prep here not
something you see every day it's
difficult to get these twenty-eight
hundreds out of their preparation yeah
Rory managing to do it
and scoring a full point for the
unicorns let's this round is look let's
let's keep an eye on yeah like the
Skippy what do you this game this one
looks what is anybody introducing any um
oh interesting ideas not not so much but
there's some people in the chess calm
shed thinking maybe Daniel is looking
for a drop which which I definitely
agree with her takes g3 was a drawing
idea hoping for a simple crash career
petrol no after Rick d3 lien Lee is
renewing the threat to the rook on e8 so
black will have to defend this rook so
Ricky to is how he decides to do this
and now white simply plays rook e1 and
what is looking to be quite a bit more
active I like this position yeah I think
white has some very good chances notably
after it takes a one and Queen takes a
one there's going to be some threats on
the back rank that also on f7 pawn
because this room here is kind of
misplaced and there is no way you can
actually bring it back to dead to where
it should be and in fact after move like
King G - I think f3 is threatening to
win the rooks yeah there are a lot of
interesting ideas so I are like this
district this has been a nice
development a number of threats that the
black has to deal with
sure and I'm not actually sure what
black is thinking about to my eyes you
kind of have to take this rook
I guess Bishop h6 but I don't really
believe in this this tactic I'll just
move the Queen out of the way right yeah
so yeah I'm not sure what Danya is
considering here but maybe rook e1 seems
like a party does this work mate
Queen B - Queen takes B - I guess and
then Ricky yay okay
but if Queens has changed and then King
is seven yeah I mean simply Knight takes
of seven yeah it seems pretty nice oh
this is what's being played now I met
her mr. Hale also oh the bishop comes to
f8 but yeah this is Sirica threes is
killer the other thing I was thinking
about was if you could do it just
somehow try to prepare for f3 maybe like
with Knight e4 but I mean I yes sir
mm-hmm aiyla yeah maybe what I think
okay so Knight takes f5 is and now this
suspicion when I fade is still pinned
yeah and so white will regain the peace
here and in fact possibly more I think
work F takes o Orakei takes sometimes
I'm wrong
and now what's going on in this endgame
white does seem to be up upon for the
moment but that's a for bond is kind of
a little dangerous to be honest yeah but
I think I can play work eight to f7
check and then uh after King g8 I'll
play rook a7 and I'm creating some
checkmating threats around your king
right right and that's I think exactly
is about to happen okay seven makes a
lot of sense then I can play things like
rookie five to threaten check me things
like route takes h5 just the qg - so
there's no checks no i want to get chest
i want to live on the edge
rookie five that's that's my move here
even rick c5 threatening to take this C
pawn with similar ideas but I think
Ricky five makes makes a ton of sense
here you just threaten checkmate and
there's not much black can really do
about it
I wanna keep the focus on this game
because I feel like this is um I'm
playing like Liam leoric e5 and just
resigns yeah I think we're at take stage
5 and yes there's not much to be done
here Y can always play this rook on the
fifth rank back to the a file if the a
pawn gets a little bit too out of
control and nothing to be done for the
black the black site here yeah I'm glad
about this result it was a pretty nice
one I keep on I do want to keep an eye
on this so is this game cuz the last
time I looked at it it was kind of them
getting a little it wasn't looking good
for Wesley yeah well is it looking
slightly better no it looks looks better
Oh black does have two knights for the
rook so it's not a full piece in this
case and while the two Knights are
definitely worth more than the rook they
can sometimes be a little bit more
difficult to coordinate than any other
pair of minor pieces right even much
rather have a bishop and a knight or
especially two bishops the two knights
together sometimes step on each other's
toes and I think that's going on just
just a little bit here in this position
you see the Knights defending each other
but they're also difficult to move from
this kind of interlocked position well
now G poor might be coming up yeah G
fort is a definite threat the King is on
the perfect square
to avoid any checks from these Black
Knights rookie five also seems like a
pretty reasonable threat pinning the
knight on f5 to the rook and so we do
see knight c6 but no five yeah b5 and is
is white winning all of a sudden these
Knights are just a little awkward if you
move this Knight anywhere then rookie 5
picks up the night maybe knife has to go
to e7 with in June 97 g4 I think Wesley
is is picking back up his material I'm
not sure it's enough to win because
there's so few pawns left on the board
but it should be good enough to I mean
decent enough time yeah he is slightly
up on the clock against Steven here and
I think Steven let this one slip he had
a definite advantage
against Wesley so yeah b5 and now G for
should be very very nice for for Wesley
why don't we check back in on money A's
game against daro we haven't seen this
one just yet so Lenny a here in a minor
piece end game which looks okay for him
maybe looking looking for a draw and
this one is black hair you just have
slightly less space makes it a little
bit uncomfortable so I think all black
can really do is is pass here you want
to let white take the time to move
either the night or the King out of the
way and then you can expand with b5 but
until that point I'm not sure you want
to do too too much right I feel like
something like if you touch the c3
Knight then b5 is coming up so he's
actually bring you a nice to help the
this pawn march on the King side so you
kind of are a little bit just stuck
because you can't really move the
Knights you can until you move the King
what's the same applies for black black
can't really move any of the pawns move
the King so I will say for black though
so let's say linea passes with Bishop d8
if white tries to play g4 maybe I can
take g4 and after it takes g4 bishop h4
is starting to find some activity the
bishop being a long-range piece can kind
of keep an eye on these pawns yeah from
either side and then maybe after a
threat to the night the black pawns can
start to get rolling although I will say
I don't think there's any chance of of
this game not being a draw I think this
game it's just gonna be a drawing in the
end I I would just started thinking
about the move F
so we actually see exactly this happened
and now I was expecting a page four yeah
but if Bishop is for can t just play
like f5 yeah five and then I think
things are just gonna be a little bit
liquidated I'm not so sure
maybe after f5 I can play ticks and if
you take I'll play Bishop to e1 I just
want to hit this night and make it move
somewhere awkward okay so there should
be seven instead but still I would
expect f5 right yeah five six not Bishop
it maybe now Bishop h4 although you do
have to be careful here instead of
playing east six white might try to play
f6 I'm going to use dings e six at a
later date now comes with more force
because the F pawn is even further
advanced f7 f8 might become a nasty
threat I do think though Eleni I still
has this game well well in hand
yeah they're uh we do have another
result obviously so whoops did win this
game so as expected Wesley picked up a
one of those nights so there are eight
points it was simply updation we have
eight so we have tied the match
officially and with a draw in this last
game which is what we expect we would be
going home with with the victory
regardless of what happens in the fourth
round yeah that's actually uh oh my
goodness and that is a piece but then c4
check will trade off the last pond and
we will have an official drop daro
though a true fighter keeps the final
pawn on the Bernie but this one is this
is this is a bit silly at this point
there's no way lineage
losing this game of course you can
always go for some silly night Forks Wow
okay posit the pawns are exchanged and
the game is drawn and I want you into
the ship material nice so seeing them
stars bishops definitely going to have a
victory in this match with our score
after three rounds being eight and a
half to three and a half you still have
one more round to go though and I
definitely want to keep scoring some
more points to to get even further ahead
in the league standings yeah especially
bid with the next game being with our
hardest applause yes so of course in the
final round of these protests League
matches board one plays board one or do
plays board two and so on so it is in a
sense the most fair matchups but in a
sense also the most favorable for us
because our best players have a really
good chance of beating their best
players and our board fours are very
very favored against against any other
board for in the league so next round
we're hoping to score some more points I
will say they kind of let me down when
we scoring two and a half points in
round three so if we can get three and a
half and Round four I'll be happy my
average of three will be met and no
English you really do want your three
points see yeah I want that that twelve
point finished to really prove that we
deserve first I asked for 12 to 14 right
well 12 to 14 yeah you were a little
more ambitious than me I'm just asking
for 12 three points around I wasn't
going with 16 I give our guys a little
bit of room for a breather so yeah just
give them that a little bit of space for
for the occasional slip ups that are
that are always done to happen but why
don't we take a look at the results for
round three
Bobby karamaneh did defeat group wait a
second is that true grigory Oberon
actually defeated Fabi carrot water yeah
in this last round scoring a fool I love
that to be true but I think we're we're
amending the ground
yeah yeah there then Fabiana
unfortunately did lose to Grigory yes
very interesting opening yeah the world
number two
definitely yeah the missus preparing for
yeah once again a huge shout out to
Christian shrila starting up a salute
starting up on the Mizzou chess team
earlier this year so sister team yes
blue sister team uh while it is in its
infancy as a chess program they already
have incredibly strong players such as
Gregorio oprand
who has been playing in some fairly
elite tournaments I believe he was an
Iowa man this year as well as the World
Cup a lot of places he's been playing a
lot of chests well yeah continues his
education according to what I understood
because visited sent a team to China to
for the world prestigious tournaments
you send the team is assigned a team and
from what I remember
grigory was telling that he has out he
has already an undergrad degree from
another university back in I'm not
mistaken a Russian University makes them
and yeah so it was pretty interesting
that's like somebody gets a degree in a
different University and they come here
and they're just pursuing another degree
playing their chest it's yeah the
incredible collegiate programs here in
the United States that are are being
started up in these past few years it's
a very nice way to develop your chest
career yeah that being said let's take a
look at the actual results before Oprah
n-- takes out Bobby Cara wanna a tough
day for Fabi two losses definitely not
what we expected to see
but no worries because the rest of the
team is picking up the slack Lenny at
Dominguez draws their board one Darrow's
roots Wes Lisa defeats Stevens York
after a little bit of a shaky game and
Liam Lee takes out Daniel nerd
ski in a a nice technical conversion I
think this double rock end game and then
you did everything right and Stan you'll
had to resign yeah
so once again that brings the total
scores to three and a half to eight and
a half eight and a half is the magic
number so we have officially won the
match with four games left to go so now
we're just we're looking for the gravy
on top just just trying to get some
extra points for the league standings
and why don't we see those standings for
this final round of course yet parents
parents yeah not not standings we have
Daniel nerd it's gate against Wesley so
Stevens ear against Liam Lee Bobby Cara
wanna against daro spirits and money a
dominguez against Rory Oberon so of
course that's the the even matchups all
the way down the line board one against
board one for two against for two and so
on and so forth and so this is the true
test of the teams and historically in
these past three weeks round four is
really where our team has has shown
yeah last week we want like three and a
half two hundred things like that he's
got three and a half to two 1/2 in the
week before I think we actually won for
Oh against the UK lions in that final
round
so in these even more even matchups this
is where the Archbishop's have really
pulled through in this final round yeah
I completely agree
um especially with I'm already starting
to think about the next week game yeah
against the chest bra some people ya
know for yeah when do I know the their
their lineup probably about or the
weekend yeah I'm not sure when that will
be officially announced I think in the
coming days we will have those official
pairings once again here is the upcoming
schedule for next week the Canada chest
bras are our opponents in the Western
Division starting at 10:00 a.m. Pacific
time that is 12 p.m. local st. Louis
time here be sure to mark your calendars
clear your schedules because that will
be the matchup of the league honestly I
think these are the two strongest teams
in the entire pro chest league not just
our division so this will be one to look
out for
especially heading into the playoffs
later this year so we'll take on the
Canada chess bras if you're interested
you can check out all these other teams
but I don't know why you would because
the Archbishop's are the only ones that
matter we're gonna win the entire league
so you'll definitely want to see every
step along the way here that would be
ideal
we would love to be here for every
single commentary do all of those be
here for the summer series I love it
bring my can with his every like every
single medal and the trophies and that
being so cool I don't want to say too
much but if if you're a Mike comer fan
out there you'll definitely want to tune
in next week maybe a recap of that would
be really cool of course we've had three
opponents so far well now now four
opponents that that have been lined up
and managed defeat absolutely all of
them so we'll see if we can keep that
going go seven and oh and in the regular
season here and launched us into a
successful playoff oh we do have games
of starting at the final round is
officially underway
so Bobby of course playing daro the
[Music]
California unicorns board won't forgot
their name for a second with a name like
the unicorns I don't know how I could
but here we have a Roy Lopez once again
so white of course cannot capture on a
five the previous turn comes Queen d4
would be a fork so you have to be
careful of some of these tactics
yeah oh well I I was right we have way
too many Berlin's this is the fourth one
I've done it's it's enough yeah it's
enough to be tired of them but it's I
mean what are you gonna do it's one of
the best defenses for black yeah it's a
tough nut to crack and we'll see Bobby
make the effort here Queen e2 is an
interesting
and after Knight d7 what what's the idea
here for both sides yeah G for I think
was was always going to come for white
and not maybe wait'll continued to
expand on the Kings side since he has
not yet committed his King to to
castling on that side of the board so
Queen e2 does defend this F to pawn
which is why black had to play 97 to
defend e oh yeah Queen d4 tactic was no
longer available but someone g6 just
feels kind of misplaced I tend to agree
and there's some annoying pressure on
the e5 pawn here but no probably black
looks to queenside castle and play move
like f6 reroute this bishop to the f7
square and I have have natural squares
for his pieces
I don't mind flex position at all here I
think black is doing quite alright we do
see Queen side castles like I said I
expect f6 and something like Bishop f7
to come and black will have a solid
position as is standard for this Berlin
yeah this is um I feel like this is this
game is going pretty logical I like I I
still like white more just because well
simply in my eyes the game is still
pretty closed and to bishops not as
ideal in close close center positions
and also the the Knights can jump into
so many squares f5 is well thank you for
yeah the f5 is one of those and then
whites could start them pawn march on
King side I like this yeah it looks
white definitely has some ideas here I
do want to mention we actually already
have a result
Daniel Meredith he has drawn his game by
repetition against Leslie so out of the
opening I think Danya realizing that the
match is already over might as well just
actually and the trustees yeah what
Wesley mentioned that it's it's past
midnight where he's at but apparently
the other ones who knew less of the
globe
but Wesley wanting to get to bed ended
this game rather quickly and that's
that's all she wrote for this match so
up to nine to ninety four in the total
match score yeah I'm very glad I mean
we've already won the match but the more
points we get of course but now I mean
then again not a bad idea to just secure
a half point yeah you know every every
half point counsel I guess so if he
wanted to play for a win that would have
been great but he had the black pieces
scoring a half point well I was kind of
more worried about not that the other
three guys have to win so that's our
ideal 12 happens if you really want or
three in half you know I've got a lot of
faith I've got a lot of faith in these
guys although I will say looking at
linear Dominguez this game perhaps the
Sun is heading to a draw as well that is
a lot of weight
what are you can play King you won I
guess to try to keep the game going
white is up the exchange but the King
looks rather weak here on castles yeah
are you it well the castle the money on
Castle I guess is the point but how do
you protect this this King well he's
very difficult I think it's not about
the King as much as it's about the rook
on a1 you really have to get that guy
out yeah so I think it's more the
question should be more like how are you
gonna get your pieces out so maybe you
move like rookie three but then simply
Queen takes h2 and it's not so easy to
get developed yeah I guess you could
just play king d2 but then it when's
your queen so you can't beat it was very
difficult to get develops um I was kind
of
ideally okay rookie treat does seemed
like seems most natural yeah gives your
King a little bit of space after Queen
h2 maybe black or white will simply play
King eetu she's trying to get these
pieces into the game but now black has
collected a couple pawns I'm gonna
Queenie to both Queen okay we do see
King e 2 actually and then if Queen h5
check I think rook f3 that's what and
somehow someway white is hoping to get
and completely untangled here and from
there I'll try to play for an advantage
using this extra exchange with that a
month there is one more game in progress
that is the game of Stephens York
against Lee M Lee why don't we see how
how this one is progressing rather
strangely it looks like black still
stuck in the center here but has a nice
central majority with this d6 e 5 as
well as c6 all these palms together okay
so good news is Castle is a still legal
castling is legal excellent good to know
but so maybe some achieving so of course
if Queen e6 check black wants to respond
with queenie says just evicting this
Queen right away
I was singing maybe something like oh
yeah Queen f7 I I think is pretty
natural and now if the Queen's are
traded the black king is a lot happier
and these two bishops can start to shine
so I think why should try to avoid this
trade somehow maybe a between a for to
keep pressure on c6 could be an idea but
then I think black will will king site
castle and actually was a threat to the
f2 pond that White has to immediately
deal with
how about Knight something like 96 does
that even work
96 looks very I think King e7 might win
a piece somehow ribbon hanging pieces
less than right a king e7 attacks the
knight and the knight is pinned to the
Queen oh wait maybe there's a queen edge
for my queen takes h6 King takes okay
yeah Queen f6
it's interesting I'm just shooting up
loose because I really yeah this one
looks a little bit crazy so maybe 96
I'll play Bishop d2 the idea of Bishop
takes on C 3 followed by king e7 it's
it's pretty deep
it's pretty deep but maybe 96 can't be
right though it's just the nice nice so
instead we do see the Train of the
Queen's and now I think the black will
have a pretty comfortable position here
it was like a 5 come - mines always
against tonight on b3 this Afia for push
is very natural it would also go very
nice if we could open up the b7 Bishop
yeah but see if I'm kind of nice always
yeah yeah I expect to move like like a 5
maybe it's just finger up top I think so
cuz it's not yeah cuz if not a 1595
would also be an idea source yeah I
think this one is looking slightly
favorable for it for Lee and Lee I'm
being honest with you this knight on e4
it does challenge this d6 pawn so we see
Europe come to d8 I expect no maybe Rick
a to d1 adding a little bit more
pressure to this pawn and then what kind
of has has his choice of ways to defend
it you can play moves like King e7 move
like King e6 but King e6 puts you on a
square you can be checked so you gotta
be careful careful of that so we do see
Rick d1 and now I would expect King King
e7 I don't think Bishop f8 is what you
want to be doing so we do have another
result so we have a second draw this
game of Lynnea Dominguez against
Gregorio prymus was also drawn simply by
repetition
this Queen h5 move was too strong
Lenny I didn't want to risk playing rook
f3 kind of making his pieces awkward so
they repeated with King f1 and Queen h1
and then
to age five completely understandable
okay yep so that brings the score nine
and a half to four and a half ruining my
dreams of a 12-point victory however
there are still two games left to play
and if we win both of them we almost got
there with 11 and a half that's not bad
at all um let's take a look at
Fabiana where's the star use cuz we
haven't looked at this in a little while
so you mentioned you preferred the
Knights in this position to the bishop
sense you mentioned white might expand
on the King saw and so white definitely
has expanded on the King said some files
have opened up and it looks like the
Knights are are you know performing
quite well in fact we do see black trade
off this LightSquared bishop for the
night and now do you take back with the
beep on with the D pawn or with the
Knights looks another C pawn
yeah beep on like just looks pretty
natural to me as well wait a second is
c3 winning upon here
I guess g5 is under attack I'm sorry
it's okay the stuff that's been hanging
yes so these few games probably yeah
just just bring the bishop back to D and
now you could think about C tree think
about c3 think about a move maybe Queen
g3 putting more pressure on this a5 pawn
and things like rook f6 also come to
mind everything is looking quite nice
for father here I think he has a lot of
great options
this looks pretty pretty nice I'm not
really worried about it at all yeah I'm
a big fan of fabi's position actually
III don't know what black is planning to
do about any of these ideas c3 Yorick a
6 Queen g3 like I said all great options
for her Fabi here and I don't think
black can do much to stop them
so I like Bobby's position a lot I'm
expecting him to pull this one out as
always he's like four and a half minutes
up on the clock I don't know how he does
this every game he just moves instantly
and is like immediately
he has like double his opponents time
out of the opening
it's kind of crazy yeah let's take a
look at Leon these games yeah I think
this is the one that to keep an eye on
here can Liam Lee expand in the center
safely I think is the main question to
be answered here if he can then he'll
have a definite advantage with these
bishops and with the strong center if
you can't then probably the game's draw
so the good news is I don't think he is
at much risk at all of losing this game
unless disaster strikes and he he
manages to you know and now we see rook
before this is a really nice move I'm a
big fan of this move yeah it highlights
the fact that that white had just played
h4 and this move does create a weakness
for white if he isn't careful now a
threat might be simply to play d5 and
Rick takes h4 but not b3 is weak so just
bring the rook back and keep pushing on
b3 c3 he's not to move that white one
into play I this creates definite
weaknesses and and certainly more
targets for for black to aim at simply
something like rook b6 now and or even
rip back to be it
and this b3 pawn is under fire how do
you defend it I'm not so sure
turns out you go wait a second what D 5
D 5 knight c6 to pieces at the same time
okay but there is there is a point this
time around we have to wait is there's
some credit but what about rook takes b3
I guess you're taking on d6 yes okay I'm
convinced
what about Bishop takes c4 I guess
you're recapturing and then okay this is
what is what is actually played here now
maybe my rook can can start invading
rook b3 maybe Rick b2 just invade attack
this this week' for pawn attack the weak
c3 pawn and I think this is still going
to be pretty favorable
for Liam Lee here yeah not not much to
say black just has slightly more active
rooks and these Center pawns are a
little bit less week than I think that
the way you could just try and go after
the a for pawn yeah I like a move like
rook b2 with the idea of rook a to and
just capturing on on a4 it looks simple
enough but it is a concrete threat that
white doesn't have a very good way to
stop all right let's go back on Bobby's
game yeah I think Bobby's game is
heating up just a bit we did in fact see
this rook land on the f6 square and now
I guess but one of the white knights was
traded off for that black Bishop on d4
and now we see the black knight landing
on the d4 square
I guess rook takes c2 or Knight takes c2
is in fact a threat here so Fabi has to
do something about it I do just wonder
off the top of my head if I play move
like Brooks D - yeah just just rip d2
like yeah I like that simple and the
fact is g6 is going to be a very very
very weak pawn as a c6 and I think
something something is going to fall so
the thing is it works thank you if your
teacher would have Queen of shades uh
all right Thank You Sweeney chick does
that hang g6 maybe I rotational on is
coming up yeah Oh wreckage one you know
you make a point but maybe I guess this
move ur kef - anyways would have solved
would have solved twice problems getting
allowing Erick f1 and now rook after
eight might be a threat to come I have
to remove like Queen f1 work out seven
as well hits this f2 pawn in fact Rick
f7 here might be very very very powerful
work out seven what is what is black
play
I mean there there are some moves like
96 I suppose maybe King b2 is a simple
idea for white you just step out of this
your cage one threat o Bishop takes c7
well I'll be finding some tactics here I
guess after King takes we're gonna play
Queen a5 check followed by Rick f7
followed by checkmate I love it oh and
that's exactly what's happening here
yeah this is checkmate isn't it just
looks like checkmate to me I was
thinking maybe look at seven Jake first
and then tries to find good the Queen
not just Queen a five yeah
the King has no good squares if you go
to d7 first I think I'll take on a 7 and
then district up 7 should be good too
well we nice 7 if King e8 Queen f7 is
made if King c8 and then work f7 I think
is fair enough I as long as we get my
time I don't care how it happens
yep so Bobby finding the nice tactic if
I should take c7 and the black King
simply has no vertical this game is over
that was very nice yeah Bobby two
devastating losses two incredible wins
so I guess it balances out for for
Fabiano honestly I liked his wins enough
to make up for his losses here it was
some really beautiful stuff especially
that first one with with all the pawns
rolling forward I love to see that yeah
let's let's go back to this other game
of three only
yes this is definitely being made and
what is happening the white rooks did
actually find activity I'm not really
thrilled about that but maybe d4 I also
think maybe King nope never I think I
was not saying d6 in 94 right that those
would be two chess moves I don't oh we
have a results awesome so Fabi did win
this game against our odar resigning
before
checkmate was about to be played and
that brings our total score to ten and a
half hopefully we're going to make it
eleven and a half oh let me just help
out here for a second
thank you oh all right got all the files
back on the board nice and easy for is
actually Leung Lee's choice to take it
to you this game before is very
combative I hangs this deep on but but
yeah you can just sleep on f3 he takes
up three in C three hangs as well and
you've opened also be a king a little
bit well maybe a Bishop III Bishop takes
e5 c5 rook c3 yes
in fact we're takes a four would also be
be possible there Jack this is looking
to fizzle out though if you go into one
of those concrete lines where where you
trade all the pieces then it's
definitely just gonna be a draw I think
blacks remaining winning chances are if
he just simply takes on c3 and that goes
for some checkmating ideas against the
exposed white king and well it might not
be technically like forcing but I think
it does give blacks in some good
practical chances here I agree this is I
mean this is kind of Boston 94th oh I
don't like this decision from white
allowing blacks hood to keep this f3
pawn seems very very dangerous in fact
Bishop III you can't play King f1 do to
check me and is f2 just going to Queen
so you have to play like King age - yeah
- rookie one bye-bye
yes King H - f - like you have to play
rugby you want oh wait what about this
before I'll be sure before just picks up
there up yeah course this is simply
winning I mean have to [ __ ] you can even
start with F - if you like but yeah I
think I like this better
yeah King H 3 I'll pick I'll take free
rook oh um okay as nothing I could even
like take FG to first yeah now F takes G
- I think it's very very natural and
then Rick takes a 4 and this game is as
well in hand for Lee and Lee looking
like a victor here I don't know why I
didn't just capture on f3 I think that's
it seems very reasonable I'm not sure
maybe it's awesome ghost though after it
takes c3 there are a lot of rooks I'm
getting getting near that white King but
I certainly would have been better than
but what happened here in the game now
yeah rookie 7 is forcing a trade of
rooks I suppose you can play King of 6
here I thinking a6 is the good move K
mean um either of them should be good
enough yeah King f6 followed by h6 50s
this night from from its outpost here
King f8 also doing it safe that's good
96 Chuck maybe King g8 now to step out
of any Knight checks of course this the
square - diagonal steps away from the
knight isn't the most difficult square
to be checked from just some Chester
you're done takes a sec takes the knight
like three moves to check a king yeah
from two squares away like that so good
stuff from Liam Lee he picks up the c3
pawn and now it'll pick up the g6 phone
as well and with the two full pawns even
if one Falls up the exchange against the
night this is going to be going to be a
win
oh if king g5 rook c6
g6 King G King f6 take it ah yes so the
line you're saying was about yeah simply
resignation of course you're saying if
king of six then we can take this Knight
yeah go into the King upon ton game yeah
so that actually concludes the match we
finished on eleven and a half to four
and a half
not quite the twelve point goal I set
for the team not quite the twelve to
fourteen range you set for the team
almost like certainly a very good score
for the Saint Louis I'm very happy
especially because this was it was a
very we had a very interesting start
yeah it was a little bit of a rocky
start although we did end up with a
favorable score in in every rounds with
getting a couple two and a half seer at
the ends and then get them getting a
couple three points as as well yeah one
three and a half Oh favorable in every
rounds ending on eleven and half to four
and a half we get that 10 point bonus
pushing us to 21 and a half in the
league standings and now once again this
is the important game next week we face
the Canada chess pros they were the
league leaders going into today's round
I'm not sure how today's scores have
affected things but likely they're still
in the lead but next week at 12 p.m.
Central Time
10:00 a.m. Pacific time we faced the
Canada chess draws the only team also
undefeated in this Western Division and
we will be looking to take them down
this may determine the final standings
in the Western Division if things
continue as expected next week we'll
decide it all for first place and we
definitely want that first place spot it
gives is a huge step up in the playoffs
I think we get another bye week if we
have also thinking is there another like
points bonus if when we win the or I'm
sorry like when you win your division
are there any point bonuses um so when
you win the division I believe you get
an extra buy into the playoffs so you
would have to win one less man one for
your matches
in order to get to that final four I do
want to mention next week it's not quite
the the perfect team that we see here
but it is very very close for those
Jeffrey Zhang fans out there be sure to
tune in next week it is going to be
another team full of 2700 plus players
board one will be Lenny a Dominguez
board to Wesley so board three Liam Lee
and then Jeffrey Zhong will be the
killer board for look out for the
American youngster making his protest
League st. Louis Archbishop debut of
course he played on other teams in the
past this is his debut as an archbishop
it will be fun to watch him take on the
chest drawers in the match that that
might decide it all for the regular
season here yeah I think it's the first
time ever did I remember that's Bobby I
know his ends playing yeah Bobby you
played every week I think actually I
don't know if that's true but maybe
maybe every week up until this point so
he won't be playing next week but we
will still have a team full of 2700 s be
sure to tune in next week for all of
that action and thank you so much for
joining us this week for our match
against the California unicorns and yeah
huge congratulations to the Archbishop's
thank you thank you yeah I'm very glad
with our results it's could have been
slightly better but good enough I'm
gonna happy good enough for me so once
again thank you so much for joining us
and we will see you next Monday
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you